tomorrow will just be like literally
like you are cheating I don't care and I
used to get angry
but now I'm just like hey I'm not
cheating I love you and this is where
I'm at and this is where I'm going and
I'll text you when I get there and I
just have to do like the extra to like
make her feel safe even if it feels
annoying yes and whether you
like it or not you're my new therapist
you know straight up this is great you
understand the irrationality my only
hope is like watching a movie and then
like the girl character does something
stupid and then my girls like oh my gosh
this girl's so annoying like she's being
so rational and why would you say that
yeah what is it about her behavior and
I'm going to use the movie as a conduit
to be like that's what you can do it's
so annoying I'm just going to call you
up you put on her special yeah